this
is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
my name is anthony o'neil host of the
popular youtube
and podcast show the table with your boy
anthony o'neil and co-hosting with me
today is the one and only christy wright
number one national bestseller uh also
host of the very popular
the christy wright show and also uh the
founder of
the business boutique academy that's
opening up next week
it is on monday and we're kicking it off
with a webinar i'm so excited i'm gonna
teach people how to sell
without feeling slimy feel good about
selling
and we're gonna kick it off so yeah it
opens on monday closes on thursday so we
just open a few days but man there's a
lot of excitement that builds
up to this time of year when we get our
new class of academy members into my
coaching group it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be real fun so if you have
any questions about business today
business money uh
i wanna say relationships yeah
relationships uh anything today give us
a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five five two two five and
christy and myself would love to
give you our viewpoints our thoughts um
and help you walk through
uh this process so i'm excited chrissy's
in her business head mode today
um so when she walked in she said hey i
want business calls i want business
calls maybe we'll give away an academy
membership if we get some good business
calls
i love giving away your stuff you just
santa claus aren't you just getting it
so generous hey yo so give us a call you
never know you may uh
may be the person to get it triple eight
eight two five five two two five kelly's
standing by
uh she's our boss today her and james
and they'll let us know if you get
through
but lenora is with us in texas good
afternoon uh how can we help today
uh hi yes i'm calling because me and my
husband were kind in dilemma
we moved here from arizona and we paid
off all our debt we're about two hundred
and twenty thousand dollars free of debt
and we have a house yeah we have a house
here in texas and a house in arizona
but my husband recently got the
opportunity to move to east texas to
give the kids a little bit more
opportunity as well for me to get my
master's degree
and i'm kind of at the point where i'm
like i'm comfortable here we don't have
like a mortgage payment to pay and if we
were to move over there
it was like we're starting all over
again and
he's for it and i'm kind of on the fence
so i was calling to see if you guys
could give some kind of
advice on what we should do yeah so
let's walk through this process and i'm
gonna let chrissy talk into this a
little bit too cause she's married and
i'm pretty sure her and her husband have
disagreed on some things and
i would love to hear how do we work
through that because it's gonna happen
within marriages and relationships but
um what's y'all's household income right
now
um my husband's
like his pay i guess per month varies
but anywhere from
seven to eight thousand and i'm a nurse
i just finished
my bsn program so i'm gonna
start working i just had a baby so
congratulations
yeah congratulations thank you okay cool
so you're making about eight thousand
dollars a month
um and you said that you all paid off
all your debt or do you still have some
debt i know you say paid off 220 is that
all of your debt
yeah that is all of our debt that's our
student loans our medical bills our
house everything how much is the house
worth um
the house in arizona we bought it um we
bought it when we were
20. and we paid it off this last
like two years ago and i think the value
on it's like 280 and the one in texas is
about 75.
it's a little older house so okay and
you said he wants to move there and get
a new house and you all will have a
mortgage payment there
yeah like we live in texas right now we
live
over here around odessa midland and the
house is completely paid for so we're
basically paying just like water
electricity
phone internet just basic um like they
yeah and if we were to move over there
it's like we're having to start
with the mortgage and hoa and all the
basic bills and still
i mean i get the reason why he wants to
go just because he's closer to the beach
and
it's it has more opportunity for the
kids to grow
the little town that we're in right now
doesn't really have it's like one stop
sign
like a one four-way stop and that's it
you know so i think he's for it because
it gives more opportunity for
our kids to grow but i just i mean i
remember
struggling being able to pay the bills
when we lived in arizona and i just
don't want to go
backwards why what's the arizona house
for is that a rental
what's that what are you yeah it's it we
we just
we we're renting it it's a rental right
now but
a couple about last july the house
burned down
so it's getting remodeled right now
through the insurance company
why would you not want to sell that
house
because ultimately our goal is to move
back to arizona
so okay i mean i think that's where we
want to move back
but when do you know we're just um we
were planning on moving back within like
the next five years
um but i mean the five years have
already came and go so we're kind of
like well what are we supposed to do
like is that where we want to go so
we're kind of
at a loss of what like we're supposed to
go what we're supposed to do
but he just feels like he was already
frustrated where he was at and
he felt like there was no growth and
then all of a sudden like someone's like
hey you know what i have a position for
you
and i think he feels like you know god
works in mysterious ways like maybe this
is a sign for us to move like maybe
there's more opportunities more growth
like
well i think there's definitely i think
there's definitely you guys can have a
discussion about whether you move or not
i mean that's that's one piece of the
the equation
but it makes the way that you ask the
question is this as if there's only one
way to do it and there's not there's a
couple ways to do it
you could sell the arizona house and you
could pay cash for a house and you don't
have a mortgage again
and you could sell your house as well
you know one of the things i've heard
dave say a lot of times anthony on the
show is that
he never recommends long distance
landlording
long-distance rentals um you've already
experienced a headache of that thing
burning down and having to remodel and i
can't even imagine what that's like
trying to manage from texas
but if i were you if i were in your
shoes and i'm just gonna say what i
would do if i were you
i would sell both houses pay cash move
to this new opportunity and then you
still don't have the mortgage
that's just me ao what am i missing
something that's just i don't know
yeah from from the financial perspective
um i agree with christy i mean once i
pay off my whole mortgage
i'm not a fan of going back into debt
you know
um if i can sell both of them yeah so if
i could pay off both of the houses
i may not pay off sell both of the
houses move
pay cash for the house um that's the
route that i'm going
now are you completely wrong if if you
go out there and take another mortgage
you're not but why do you want to go
backwards that would be my question
so i think for me uh what christie and i
are saying is
you two just need to really sit down and
have a heart-to-heart conversation
uh you be honest with your husband allow
your husband to be honest with you and
you two figure out what's
best for the family moving forward
and i think one of the best things
especially with you all just having a
baby
and you just completing school and you
all being a young couple
avoiding debt avoiding going back into
debt
is the best thing for the couple
and you hear it in her voice she doesn't
want to now it's different if someone
calls and it's like they don't feel that
conflict i feel like she would regret it
right getting another mortgage and you
don't want to go against your values i
hear it in your voice you don't want to
do that
yeah yeah yeah i totally agree with you
chrissy and that's that's why it's
important for her to
have the conversation and be honest with
her husband like hey
i hear you babe but this is this is
what's in my heart this is what's in my
gut
so can we please please avoid this hey
triple eight eight two five five two two
five it's christy wright anthony o'neil
right here on the ramsay show
we wanna hear from you when we come back
give us a call
oh
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you
make the most out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsey personality
john david studio with me today is
christy wright also ramsey personality
and number one national best-selling
author
and marie is with us in columbia south
carolina who's going to kick off this
segment
how can we help you um i'll call them
because
um i think you guys are taking my call i
am a single mom
and i have about 30 or 35 000
worth of debt and i was wondering if it
would be a good idea
to um sell my home and take those loan
proceeds to pay off my debt
and kind of rent for this a couple years
to kind of build my credit back
up and you know kind of save more money
for a down payment on a new home
so sell your house to pay off the 35 000
in debt right now right
that's the main question how much do you
make
only by probably about thirty thirty
thousand thirty one thousand dollars
what do you do um i'm actually a
business analyst
oh okay all right business analyst all
right what's the thirty five thousand
dollars of debt
um it's ten thousand for car payments
um about 22 000 in student loans
and about 3 000 in credit cards
credit cards all right cool sounds good
and how much equity do you have in your
house
um i have about
about sixty thousand dollars worth of
faculty cool let me ask you this
question
um uh how much is your house worth
um it's about either 160 or 165.
what's your mortgage payment it's like
860.
oh okay yeah yeah you you are uh you're
stretching this one
ain't you married yeah yeah it's a
struggle
okay so so i want to ask one question
before we it's a little different than
the
the paying off the debt with the house
um what would it look like to get your
income
up what would that look like in your
business a business analyst i would
think that that
you know could could have some potential
to be making some good income
i know you're a single mom so side
business may not you may not have the
hours for that have you considered
um what what a path to that might look
like i i know that sometimes we're like
we want the house to be the last thing
to go
the last thing to use to pay off debt so
you know with your
uh you know your experience as being a
business analyst i would just feel like
there's some options for you to get that
up
yeah i'm hoping for maybe a promotion in
the next
year or so but i'm kind of new in the
role
so it's yeah yeah yeah yeah
well here's the problem that we have
marie that i'm seeing i think chrissy
was hitting to it
uh we have we have a shovel problem you
know we have an income problem
and so right now selling your house
could be a temporary fix but you will be
right back in this situation
uh down the road if we cannot get your
income up and so the number one thing is
i definitely want to say we need to
start figuring out how to get you up
to at least about 50 55 000 especially
in columbia south carolina which is a
beautiful city because that's where i
was born at so i'm rooting for you
um but at the same time let me ask you
this question
money was no issue would you sell your
home
yes um i'm not really particular fond i
mean i've been in my house for
it's going on five years okay um i'm not
happy with the location anymore
um and honestly it's a lot um
to be a homeowner with maintenance and
you know
property taxes hoa fees so it's kind of
a lot that i kind of jumped in kind of
quickly i think
yeah and i kind of just want like maybe
a clean slate
i like yeah then i would definitely say
reach out to one of our
um real estate agents here um
and just get on the phone with them and
see how can you get on the market i mean
if you want to sell now is a great time
to sell
well and i wonder too if you couldn't
downsize take some of that you know
proceeds
but then you're still you know owning a
home like that might be in a better
location because i didn't
know all that marie about the location
that you want something different i just
my only fear is sometimes people think
well i don't like my situation here
so i'm going to go over here because
it's going to be easy and perfect i'm
like renting has its own set of problems
so i don't want us to think
that that's going to just solve it maybe
there's a another combination like you
said another option
there is there is let me ask you this
question um
before we let you go here do you have
anything in the savings account
i like to i have about 5 000 in savings
okay cool
5 000. so here's the thing um i would
suggest since you don't like the home
since you want to get out of the home go
ahead and sell the home now when you
sell the home you're going to pay
off all your debt and what you're going
to do is you're going to invest not
invest you're going to put three months
inside of an emergency fund okay okay so
that's the first two things you're going
to pay off all your debt you're going to
put three months of expenses inside of
emergency fund
and while you're building your emergency
fund back up you're going to rent for a
little bit
then you can do what chrissy said is
going back in there and see what can you
buy that you really enjoy
in the meantime i want you to connect
with one of our friends ken coleman
uh jump on his radio show next week ask
him
hey i talked to i tell him i talked to
chris and anthony last week
on the ramsay show they told me i have a
shovel problem you're the shovel guy i
need to get my income up any suggestions
and he'll walk you through that entire
process
on what to do and how to get your income
up but in the meantime
uh reach out to one of our elps
um and they'll walk you through the
process on how to sell your home
and get to get you out of that house and
sell it for top dollar the the
income piece of it is so huge anthony
because what i don't want her to do and
i think is really tempting for anyone to
do is when you get a lot of cash
and you're you've been strapped
financially for a long time and all of a
sudden you get this
huge amount of money you might pay off
your debt but then you might just
take your foot off the gas and go oh
i've got this big savings or oh i've got
this left over
and you're not going to have the the
urgency to get your income up you still
need to get your income up because i
don't want you getting another rental
situation or
mortgage situation that you can afford
because your income's not high enough to
support
your life and so make sure you're still
exploring that even if you sell the
house don't let that take your foot off
the gas
yeah chrissy and let's let's stay here
for a minute i think it's a good
teaching segment
one of the things that you do for ladies
which is why i'm so excited about you
launching your business academy
uh next week is would she be a good
candidate
to start a business on the side yeah so
what's interesting is if you're
a single mom and you're working every
hour that you can you're already
stretched
too thin i don't want to add stress to
single moms now if
for example if you have and i don't know
the ages of maurice kids but if you have
older kids that are in school
if you have they play sports after
school like you've got a little bit more
time maybe your hours
in your full-time job are flexible and
you could work
more hours whether it's on the weekends
or in the evenings or and you want to
and that's not going to just stress your
life out to the max
then yeah i mean it's so easy to start a
business right now so you could even
like for example marie one of the things
you could do you could use your business
analyst skills
on the side as a freelancer as long as
there's not a non-compete or something
as a freelancer for small businesses and
help
them analyze what they're doing their
goals their metrics their records all
that good stuff and so there's options
for you to earn extra income by starting
a home-based business or side business
or small business
the thing is i just want to make sure
that that people are prepared to work
because it's not just free money you
have to put work into it to
to make it work like anything but that's
definitely an option
if you've got those hours that you're
willing to allocate to that
and i asked that question because i'm
like when we talk about having a shovel
problem sometimes we go straight to hey
which is important go get a second job
or go get a pay raise
but sometimes that could be for a single
single mother like herself
you know what hey maybe i should just
start a side hobby a side a side gig
yeah you know what my first one was have
you ever heard me talk about this no
so when i worked in non-profit right out
of college i was making like nothing
like you know college graduates are
right out of college and
i wanted to move to this 40-acre farm
and it was more rent than i could
possibly afford
but it had an 11-stall barn and i was
like i think i'll just start a horse
boarding business and so i did i
used the 11 stall barn to board horses
to help me pay my rent because a similar
situation where i couldn't afford that
rent on my
income but i really wanted to live there
so i was like well i'll get my income up
i'll get my shovel up
by starting a side business boarding
horses so i did and that's how i was
able to afford to live there so yeah you
can
you can get scrappy and creative you can
use your skills your talents your
uh stuff if you've got a computer you
can right you've got a swimming pool you
can teach swim lessons sewing machines
so
you can get really creative to earn
extra income and what's cool about that
anthony
versus getting a side job is that you
set the hours and you call the shots
you set your pay you get decide when you
work when you don't on what terms what
customers you keep which ones you don't
how much you pay yourself you get to set
the rules and that's a nice benefit to
starting a business so ladies i want you
to get the training and tools you need
to take your business further
and faster with chrissy wright her
exclusive online training group
for women with businesses opens next
week april 19th
through the 22nd where can they join the
waiting list how can they do this yes
and you can join our webinar at
businessboutique.com
this is petite.com we'll be right back
well america we have this amazing couple
on the debt
free scream stage and i'm super excited
nate and tiffany and from orlando
orlando florida that's right
welcome y'all man listen all right so
how much did you pay off
we paid off forty nine thousand eight
hundred and seventy three dollars
and we did that in ten months less than
a year and what was your range of income
um so that's a tough one to say we were
transitioning doing some other things
but somewhere around 80 000 and ending
up at about 110.
110. i love it what do you do for a
living um so i'm a teacher
and then i'm also transitioning to work
for a smart investor firm all right
i am so that's we love dave ramsey i was
about to say both professions are
amazing
you know you're a school teacher you're
helping these young people out like this
right here and
in the lobby and then you come to work
with us to help more people that's right
i love it i love left so what what kind
of debt was this
uh student loans credit cards cards that
was uh mostly my student loans
okay so mostly normal people but yeah we
were very normal
oh man i love her love it so what
happened on on this journey about 10
months ago
well the journey is really quite a bit
longer than that for both of us
um my journey actually started pretty
much after a divorce
and so i was a single dad and you guys
will get to see my son soon
and i had to figure out you know how i
was going to change change my life i
followed dave ramsey previously just
hadn't been able to accomplish
what i'd wanted to accomplish and so i
started off that process
paying that off by myself and then along
came tiffany
yeah and i had read total money makeover
years ago
and so i started working on getting out
of debt but i was very
ish and um anyways when we met
we had a financial conversation very
early on i think it was date
three day three little too early
who started that conversation
but it was good i was ready for it i was
ready for that so um we had that
conversation
and then we actually did fpu when we
were engaged
so that was very good pre-marital
counseling on top of the other
premarital counseling
and um yeah so we i was very open to it
he helped me understand a lot of things
i didn't understand when
i originally read the book and we just
instantly started working together and
as soon as we got married
it we just hit the ground running wow
that's awesome what a cool
kind of season of your life to be
focused on this goal
and working as a team while also
bringing your lives together and getting
ready to get married and all that has
been a really good
kind of training ground for teamwork
because you're having to have these
conversations and having to align on
values and sacrifices and all that what
was that like
um that was really for me it was the
prerequisite class
uh but making sure that we're on the
same page um in my past i experienced
like that's
very important um so we wanted to make
sure we were setting goals we were on
the same page that we wanted to
accomplish the same things and so part
of that for us was reading
a lot of the books um everyday
millionaires was a big part for us to
be able to look at the future and say
this is where we want to be
we wrote some things down and that's
where it really
yeah we had we're already started
following the plan but once we read that
book
and we did the discussion at the end and
like answered the questions and started
answering like where we wanted to be
putting a deadline on everything
that's when like it became real and
we're both very competitive so we were
on a mission to beat
the goal that we we wrote down and we
actually did by over a year we became
debt free um over over a year
yeah sooner than what we had originally
planned wow because i'm looking at the
math i'm like if you started off making
80
you ended up making right around 110
that's gross i mean so net
half of your income was going towards
your debt
yeah so we had we were saving up for our
wedding uh in a honeymoon
we were gonna kick off after that but
then obviously uh
govid canceled our plans to go on our
honeymoon and
um really just forced us to use our
money the way that we saw best
which was to get out of debt which was
our plan and um
start our future in a way that's going
to allow us to and i went from
um part-time full-time to part-time
because of covid
then back to full-time um so that is
where that
range that big gap came from so once we
were
i was back to full-time then we were
able to put everything that we had saved
um towards our debt but we just had it
just in case
we listened to the show that's awesome
yes we would we would listen to you
we've heard you guys many hours as we
were
driving uber eats and having our
headphones in yeah to be like there is a
reason i'm delivering this food to
somebody else yeah i go back home and
eat leftovers
keep you motivated yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love it so what would you all say is
the key to getting out of debt
do you want to take that one you want
yeah sure um
i would say definitely the budget but
having the budget meeting i think the
budget
is obvious but that budget meeting every
month if not
twice a month and then for us it was
really writing down those goals putting
a deadline on it
because without that deadline we could
have easily made excuses for
like a trip or a night out or something
like that
i love it i love it we have a bunch of
kids young kids
in the studio today and they're watching
you
what would you say to the young people
listening why they should avoid
debt for me and as a teacher i tell kids
this because i deal with high school
students that are deciding where to go
to college and
of course many of them are looking at
places that are more expensive and they
can afford and i just tell them
uh it's not worth it it's not worth
giving up for me
um basically eight years after college
that i was working to pay off debt for
school that was four years long
wow so that puts things into perspective
right it was not worth it
and you did it fast it could have been a
lot longer than that absolutely right
absolutely man i love it i love it one
last thing before we bring your your son
up right you said you said
yes he's here uh what was the hardest
thing
during this process uh for me we had
uh because of the transition with her
job we had kind of paused and we were
saving up all the money
that we would pay off debt so we had a
pretty big chunk in savings and actually
having to go take that money and go back
to the one thousand dollars
and pay off all that debt which would
feel good but then we look at the bank
account it's a little stressful
uh that was a tough that was a tough
decision and also um but i think also
the most important thing we did to
actually say hey we're actually gonna do
this the right way i love it i love it
yeah
yeah i was going to say he's the saver
and i'm the spender so
my the toughest part for me was the same
thing but i had the opposite perspective
i wanted to spend that big chunk of
money and throw it on the debt
yeah and saving it and putting away and
not putting it towards the debt for me
was the hardest
yeah interesting yeah so she pushed me
to do it as
as all good wife hey i helped matt i
helped matt spend money as well it's a
gift i just really i really bring that
to our marriage
i think i'll probably help my wife spend
money too
i hope she's the the budget one
you're gonna need one uh why are you
bringing your son on up because i would
definitely want him
in this uh shot as well i gotta say man
you just heard a lot of single people
out there saying that wait did he bring
up finances on the third
date yes that is so
funny yeah it was great though hey
let's get this out of the way we got to
be on the same page all right it
accelerated all the other
important conversations that's right
that's right i wasn't going to budget
for too many dates if i wasn't sure that
she was on the same page so
let's go ahead and get this straight i
love it i love it love it man well
listen we're going to give you a copy of
rachel cruz's latest book because you
all are definitely there know yourself
and know your money um
and i'm excited for you all's future but
let's get to it nate
and tiffany uh paid off 49
873 thousand dollars in 10 months making
80 to 110
000 a year let's count it down and hear
a debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
oh man listen here you know i think the
coolest thing
christie is watching those young kids
watch
uh this older couple pay off their debt
young in real life but older than older
to them yes yes
yes yes you're right you're right yeah
thank you for correcting everybody
that's listening i can't see i'm like
they're actually quite young
yeah they are younger thank you christy
you're saving me from getting in trouble
i know youtube's like well anthony man
they're not old
i'm here to help that's what that's they
actually bring me onto the show for your
support for that reason
they really keep you out of trouble they
really do because chrissy would give me
those looks
the eyes you know cause kelly gives me
the looks through the window and james
just looks down and says oh
lord yeah but i love it man but this is
what it's all about
it's just really hearing stories like
that and i'm super super excited
for those people listening that are on
that journey listen to that debt free
scream it's gonna be you next
it sure will it's your bill hey we're
gonna be right back triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're gonna
take your phone calls
right here on the ramsay show
foreign
chrissy wright and myself anthony o'neil
ramsey personality is taking over the
ramsey show during this hour we're
excited because camilla and yaffette
are in atlanta georgia they're going to
kick off this segment for us
and good afternoon ladies and gents how
can we help
hey good afternoon hey how you doing oh
man this is so cool i mean
i love this i like this i hear it hey
how are you doing
hey what's going on man how can we help
all right uh it seems like uh camilla
and i are newly engaged and uh we have
a really really blessed dilemma which is
uh should we uh invest our money in
a new mortgage or um basically pay for a
nice
wedding um
this is like this is like the real life
show is there a show on this
this
let's get some numbers how much money do
you have and let's talk about
all the options not just either or all
the options
yeah uh yeah are we talking about just
investments or uh
the cash that you're asking us what you
should do with
yeah so it's a little bit short of 200
000
we have between us and that's including
retirement and cash on hand savings and
all types of stuff kind of wrapped up
into that but we did that math about two
weeks ago we came up with about
190 something or something like of that
nature
okay how much how much is not retirement
like actual cash yeah
combined combined between the two of us
it's about twenty three five
thousand twenty three thousand five
hundred dollars cash that we have okay
cool and what's your combined income
once you get married
that would be i believe that's
2 40. nice well done
okay how old are y'all can i ask that
question with that
32 32 yo yo that's what i'm talking
about
let's go christy okay now here go the
question you know i gotta ask this
me being the money guy you know you know
what's coming next
do you have any debt yeah
they said it kind of excited yeah
yeah how much debt do we have combined
uh for me i can speak for myself i have
about forty something thousand dollars
of student loans
okay um i did work really hard last year
and paid off my car note
okay and um and my
consumer debt okay i do i did found home
in 2018
um and that has a i refinanced last year
so
my mortgage is probably about 240
something left on me cool i'm not
worried about the house so
uh just your only debt consumer data
says forty thousand dollars in student
loans
yes that's correct okay what about you
bro how much debt do you have
all right so i'm i'm i'm got a little
bit higher but
uh it's student loans about 70 000
and then i still have 10 with just
around 9 10
000 on my car left which i'll pay off
this year okay and
so that combined is probably around 110
000.
yep yep okay and do you have a house or
are you renting
no i don't have a house um i when kobe
hit i mean i gave up my
um my place to stay at home more folks
to save up and pay rent the goal was to
buy a house
but uh i did not do that yet and camilla
how much did you say your home is worth
i don't know if you said that
oh it's well knowing the market right
now
probably around 350. okay how much do
you owe in it
240 something oh
camilla you may not like me oh no
okay all right chrissy you want to take
a you you want to go out to this what
you want to do kristen
i'm going to tell you what i would do
yeah i'm curious if it's what you're
going to say anthony
okay so normally we say the house is the
last thing to go but what's interesting
about your situation
is you got a lot of debt um you do have
a good income so this is one option it's
not the only option
but there's something i really
personally like about couples
renting the first year just because you
may not necessarily know where you want
to be
you're learning how to be a couple
you're learning how to be married you're
figuring out how to merge your lives
together and you guys in your early 30s
while you're very young
you also have 10 12 years of adulthood
of your way of doing things and so it
can look different merging your lives
at 32 versus 22 and so um i don't think
it's a bad idea to consider
renting for your first year of marriage
selling your house
paying off your debt and then buy a
house in a year you know that's that's
one option it's certainly not the only
one yeah but it's
it's one i would consider because of
your unique situation yeah
yeah yeah i like i like it all right
grab a pen and paper i want y'all to
write down
uh these things that me and chris is
going to give you um
put it or put it in your phone here's
the very first thing it has nothing to
do with money
uh one of the things i'm looking forward
to doing with my future wife is really
sitting down
and identifying our why what's the
vision for our life
where are we going what do we want uh is
what what's what does our legacy look
like what does the next three to five
years look like and so when you identify
that then it's going to give you the
energy to do what i'm about to tell you
next
all right so the number one thing that i
want to tell you all is to eliminate
your debt
100 so i'm not worried about purchasing
a new home
i'm not even worried about purchasing
and having a real big wedding if if i
was in your shoes
i'm saying okay cool baby we got to get
on a budget
and we're going to pay cash for this
wedding and you know what it's not gonna
be a twenty thousand
fifteen thousand dollar wedding you know
we're gonna get creative and
we're gonna make it a wedding that is
impactful for us
uh but it's not gonna be impactful for
our friends and for our families to be
all
no we need to set ourselves up to win to
go towards
our why and go towards our vision
so i agree with christy okay this is our
suggestions i know this younger
generation because you're in our age
bracket
and especially in atlanta they say keep
rental properties
so you can have passive income my
philosophy is i'm selling that house
with the with the revenue that i get
from the house i'm debt free
me and my wife are debt free we don't
have any kids
we have we're making 240 000 we're gonna
put
three to six months back in our seven
savings account
then we're gonna go ahead and go buy a
beautiful home down the road
within the next two years you all will
be debt free
sitting with at least 50 000 in your
savings account
and you can be a home owner with a clear
vision and a clear path
for your future and so that's what i
would honestly do y'all make great
income it's not going to take you a long
time to save up for your next house
don't think this is way far off it's not
we're making we're making the right
short-term
decision here yeah 240 000 y'all do
understand the the average household
income is less than seventy thousand
dollars
so you are like doubling a half that
almost triple
okay so you all are in a good place and
you're young
like me and christy okay so if you all
do
this and then start investing into the
stock market
into mutual funds into your 401ks you
guys
you all will be extremely extremely
extremely wealthy uh let's do this
kelly let's give them ramsey plus yes
great idea yeah as a gift uh from
christy and i and a whole ramsay team
here if dave was here he would be super
proud of you all
um and i want you all to uh go through
that
i believe if you all can do this now
when are y'all getting married we
haven't set a date yet but our families
are meeting literally this weekend so
once we do that that's going to kick off
all the planning and stuff but you said
i was going to hate you but i love this
idea
what a pleasant surprise anthony has
pleased someone with his answer
it happens maybe once a month i'm glad
you are the lucky recipients
camilla you just made my day you know i
love it
i i i love it thank you just made my day
uh just to hear you say you all like
that i mean yeah i'm telling you right
now your future is so bright the the
conversations
that will come out of you all taking
financial peace university through
ramsay plus that
uh kelly's gonna give you access to is
going to be amazing for setting the
foundation of how you manage money
moving forward not just getting out of
this predicament but moving forward how
you budget
how you set goals how you manage your
money so i'm just i'm excited at this
season of life when you're engaged
to get to have those conversations and
take that class absolutely so stay on
the line kelly's going to
get you that information um and also as
well kelly get their information too
i want to bring them on my show i like
them i like them a lot i want to
interview them on my show as well
because i think young people need to
hear this um
so yeah get their information kelly and
i'ma call them personally
and have them come on my show this is
why i get excited about doing a randy
show especially with you christy cause
we just have fun
i want you to bust into this new
marriage or mortgage show and just be
like
neither neither
pay off your debt at all you have this
like surprise
in all the episodes just you be the
neither guy listen
they don't want me to do that because i
hurt someone's feelings but it's all
good but america thank you all so much
for joining us this hour
this is the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money my name is
anthony o'neill host of the popular
youtube and pop cat podcast show
the table with your boy anthony o'neil
and co-hosting with me
is none other than the one and only
christy wright
a host of her popular podcast and
youtube show the christy wright show
and also the founder of business
boutique academy that's opening up next
week
and i'm really really excited about that
we'll talk about that a little bit a
little bit later on in an hour
but give us a call triple eight eight
two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
christie's has her business head on
today so if you are
a young lady or even a young man and you
have some business ideas or business
questions
uh give the expert a call i'm not an
expert in that field but if you want to
talk about your money
if you want to talk about your life i
love to talk about that so give us a
call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and uh to kick off this hour mitchell is
with us in dallas texas good afternoon
how can we help
hey anthony hey christy hi i love
listening to you guys i listen to uh
aos the table all the time oh man
appreciate you man that's great i love
it yeah i'm gonna give you a good answer
now i
appreciate you good start mitchell good
start all right now that i've buttered
you up
yeah um i am in college
and i'm living with my parents at home
still
uh going to a community college okay
trying to get my degree
debt-free awesome you gonna get it
debt-free
yes yes well i'm wanting to work towards
a little bit
of independence uh i'd like to
uh move out and get an apartment with a
friend
my senior year and i'm wondering if
that's a good idea
and how do i work towards that while in
college
are you working uh
only during the summers um what would it
look like for you to work all year long
to make this happen if you wanted to
happen
uh probably part-time i could i could
find a part-time job somewhere yeah well
i just i mean i think that's
that's a piece of the equation for sure
um there's there's
gonna be a cost not just financial cost
like you've got you gotta weigh out your
time
you know that type of thing but yeah um
i don't know anthony
anthony seems against this idea but i'll
just chime in and say
from my perspective if you set a budget
and many people do this in college
you set a budget and you work and you
make enough money to pay for your school
and pay for your living expenses with a
roommate or whatever you're doing
you can make that work financially we
just don't want you going into debt
now can you save more living at home you
sure can but you also gain something to
your point in independence and going out
on your own and
paying your own bills and making your
own way we just you just need to be able
to do it you got to be willing to work
and not have this free time or parties
or whatever you're doing i mean whatever
your free time is going to now is now
going to go to work so you think about
is that worth it to you
because you're going to have
independence of having a roommate and
having living on your own but you're not
gonna have a lot of free time because
between school
and working you're not gonna have much
of a life so you just have to think
about if it's worth it to you
i don't know anything you still don't
like it even if you can pay for it
it's not that i don't like it i my
question is why
i mean if you're telling me i want
independence
i want i want to know why like why why
do you do you wanna
i do but i'm 37 years old but when
you're in college you didn't want it
absolutely because i mean i live with my
mom for a season after college and i
we drove each other crazy yeah yeah but
i think at this time if mitchell was a
good steward and people just like all
right
let me sacrifice one more year stay at
home
work my butt off graduate school stack
some money and then when i graduate
college for one more year
i can be further ahead financially than
a lot of my peers
that's what i would challenge for
mitchell is to
not just think about the independence
because independence will come but how
can you have independence plus financial
security
plus a little bit ahead of the game at
the process as well
i'm not saying if he goes out mitchell
if you go out and do that
you're wrong no i agree with christy if
you do it and you don't do it with debt
that's that's cool that's great i would
just say on the flip side think about
what can you
gain by spending one more year at home
graduating debt free
it is going to be uncomfortable and
let's be real it may suck being at home
with your parents
and your parents being on your business
but i will ask yourself what do you gain
from that
how much more money do you have in your
savings account you know
and so and you said try to graduate
college debt free
i wouldn't want i want to call that out
so if you're saying
that you know if i move out i may have
to borrow 5 000
or 2 000 it's not even an option uh but
for me man
i would definitely say if i was in your
shoes if i was your son
i mean your father i would say hey son
stay home this last year
i get it i want you out of the house
trust me but when you get out the house
i want to make sure you get out of the
house and you stay out of the house
and you have a head start i'll add one
thing to that i'll say if you do decide
to live at home for another year like
anthony's saying
i'd say still work more absolutely then
use that time to save that money because
if you stay at home and have all this
free time and you don't save you don't
you don't use it to your advantage that
you have no expenses to to
save all this money like he's saying
then you're ending up at the exact same
spot you could have had a year of
independence and the same amount of
money so make sure you
take take advantage of this time still
work more i would still get a job
year-round part-time
you can choose how many hours to be able
to get ahead like he's saying i would
add that
yeah well i think there's another piece
of the puzzle here um
i have saved up money so far i have
just about uh 30 grand in savings and i
haven't tapped into any of that
uh through community college i just paid
for it so far
that's amazing but i'm going for
engineering
and that's almost full time during the
semester
you know just like i am taking classes
uh
so stay home it's okay yep
okay stay home i mean you can't work
stay home man don't stress yourself
graduate college
at the top of your class you're gonna
graduate an engineer
you're going to be making six figures
you're going to have some money in the
account
stay home don't rush don't rush to be on
your own
when you get out do it right all right
sounds good debt free hey yes you will
yes do it debt free man
because if you don't i'ma find you hey
you're already doing awesome
paying your way debt free living at home
30 grand and say
you're doing awesome yeah you're doing
awesome well done just stay on that
track you're doing great
absolutely and you got options if you
change your mind six months or a year
you wanna do something different you've
got some savings
you can get a job you can change your
mind but i i i like the fact that you're
already set up
so well you're not coming from behind
you're desperate making
you know decisions from that place
you're in a really strong place
strong place in america me and chris he
didn't disagree
i'm just adding stuff on top of what
chris is saying because if he would have
left out and he he could do it without
racking up debt and and
he can afford it cool great but i'm
thinking about how do you get the
like how do you get ahead of the game
okay you know what's so interesting this
is an interesting point that i think is
good for us to call out explicitly for
everybody listening today yeah
and you've said this before when we've
hosted before but i think it's good to
remind people
money is a reflection of your values yes
and how you spend money
is a reflection of what you value yeah
in the same light
our answers reflect what we value i
value independence
i do i don't want anybody to tell me
where to be what time to be home or
where to put my bread
i value independence so i'm gonna work
my behind off and get a second job
you you wanna you wanna secure the bag i
want you you're gonna stay home to
secure the bag
build well it's just different it's okay
it's what you value yes
i'm china i'm trying to buy lake houses
hey america we'll be right back this is
the ramsey show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
so april is financial literacy month
christy a
nationally recognized month dedicated to
talking about the importance of knowing
how money works
we've seen over the last year why it's
so important that we all including our
teens
know how to handle money the right way
if you don't know already
we created a high school curriculum
called foundations and personal finances
that teaches students the importance the
important stuff
like how to build an emergency fund
which i really wish i knew that christy
how to pay cash for their very first car
and college
build wealth give generously and so much
more
and you know i believe they have one of
the best teachers in the personal
finance uh this curriculum
um i heard there's this guy named
anthony o'neil that's teaching
a good portion of this curriculum nearly
45
of the high schools around the world get
to see this good looking brother
nearly 5 million students get to see
some comedy while they're learning about
money
but this honestly would not be possible
without the incredible work of our
teachers so this month we're celebrating
teachers
they've had a year full of unexpected
changes and a ton of stress
but they're unstoppable they keep going
and they keep serving our young people
and we're not just talking about
foundations and personal finance
teachers
it's been stressful uh a time it's been
a special time
for all of our teachers all over so to
say thank you to all of our teachers
we've
created um something called the teacher
appreciation
giveaway and this giveaway is sponsored
by mint mobile the affordable premium
wireless service
our giveaway has some incredible prizes
like five
thousand dollars cash and more
whoo man i like that teachers don't
hear thank you enough they do not hear
enough so help to help us celebrate
the teachers uh you know by telling them
i want you to enter in
at ramsolutions.com forward slash
teachers again that's
ramsey solutions.com teacher there's no
purchase necessary
uh the giveaway ends april 30th again
that's ramseysolutions.com
forward slash teacher and i'm excited
because we have
aaron from mint mobile he is with us to
help us thank our teachers and so i'm so
excited uh
to have him on with us he is the chief
marketing officer at mint mobile
hey aaron thanks so much for joining us
today man how are you doing
hi anthony hi christy and i think uh
before we get going a thank you
to all the teachers listening is in
order so thank you very much for all you
do
no thank you thank you so much and thank
you to mint mobile for uh partnering
with us to celebrate these amazing
teachers
so aaron real quick um why is it so
important uh to sponsor this teacher
appreciation giveaway for
for you and mitt mobile well i i think
it's well
one teachers have been such a critical
part
of just how we grow how we learn
combining them with financial literacy
is just
it's a fantastic idea we're excited to
sponsor and i think
you know one of the great things about
our brand is that we have a lot of these
things built into what we do
so it felt like a natural fit and a way
to give back and
very very appreciative to be here thank
you oh no i appreciate you for helping
us
so i gotta ask you know what was one of
your favorite teachers back in the days
and why did you like that teacher you
know in advance of this i actually
pulled out my old yearbooks
and i was able to remember every single
teacher from first grade through eighth
grade
uh i i it was impossible for me to pick
a favorite because
you know they all have these impacts and
i when i saw their pictures and i tell
my young picture
i remember the things they used to teach
us and i remember these moments so
i don't think it's fair to pick one when
i just think
education and the teachers in my life
have made such a
pronounced and dramatic impact you know
one of the things aaron that i
always said in high school and i'm sure
most students do you'd be in those
classes
that either you didn't like or you
weren't good at or maybe both
and i was like oh i'm never going to use
this i don't want to learn this
i'm never going to use this and that's
one of the reasons i'm so thankful
because
even though we may have to take classes
throughout our childhood
and high school that we don't like or
are good at or use foundations is one of
those classes
that is so practical that equips
students
with how to handle money that they're
gonna deal with every day for the rest
of their life
and so i'm so thankful that um you guys
have partnered with us to celebrate the
teachers especially
um these teachers that are on the front
lines teaching these foundations because
it's such
practical applicable content and lessons
that these kids will
actually use in their lifetime yeah so
aaron let me ask you this question from
your perspective
as you think about families across the
country why do you care so much about
financial literacy
well financial literacy i mean let's
start with just what
what we're standing for right like this
is about
managing and understanding our financial
lives right so
living on a budget i think what's really
great about this
is the the connection to our brand and
our dna right
living on a budget having expenses that
are fixed or known
allows you to plan better we've
constructed our brand that way
yeah not only that but
we also have things built into our
system that
feels very close to the financial
literacy programs you have
and it's a it's not it's not paying for
things you don't need so
with us if you sign up for mipmobile and
try the service
at the end of your first 90 days we
actively let you know if you should pay
us
less and it's unheard of in the space
because
we monitor you know just here's how much
data you used
each month over the first three months
yeah it looks like you're overpaying
we recommend you switch down and if at
any point you need more you can always
switch up so to me
like that helps people create their path
to financial freedom
is to be able to better manage their
budgets and that's just one of the
things that
when you at least have a plan for
financial freedom it helps me sleep
better at night because it's going to
take a while to get there
but if i have a plan i feel better about
it it's not just
hoping that it's going to happen and you
know it's so funny as i'm listening to
you talk
man it really sounds like you all have a
lot of things you all are shaking
up the wireless service i've never had a
wireless company call me
and tell me hey you should pay us less
i've never had any company
any company i'm like what's not cable
nobody's calling to tell me to pay less
listen y'all wireless companies out
there y'all need to listen to mint
mobile
um so eric what are you guys up to these
days man
well i think um you're gonna like this
too
so the thing we just launched and
one of the challenges we have is that
people don't believe
our wireless service is any good because
it only costs 15
a month yeah but the reality is it's
amazing for 15 bucks a month
and there's just this hurdle to get over
so we announced
last week that we are now giving away
the service for free
so we have a seven day free
trial okay and that will allow anybody
who has an unlocked phone to try mint
for free
uh and we're happy to do it you get a
week of it and i know with you guys
in our partnership we've even created a
special link of mobile.com
backslash ramsey and that gets people
access
to that free trial you know you know
what i like about that right there and
you all's premium
uh budgeting thing is we teach young
people
how to make a budget how to save
money okay and research options
and b and to be a really wise consumer
so i want to thank you um aaron and mint
mobile for what you all are doing
we really appreciate you coming
alongside us to sponsor the teacher
appreciation giveaway
this year and it's been great learning
more about
mint mobile and what all uh you all are
doing over there
to partner with us and so i am i am
extremely extremely
uh excited so again you guys
to say thank you to all of our teachers
we're celebrating financial literacy
month
with our teacher appreciation giveaway
the giveaway is sponsored by min mobile
the affordable premium wireless service
okay our giveaway has some incredible
prizes like
5 000 so teachers don't hear
thank you enough so to help us celebrate
the teachers
you know i want you to tell us who you
know
or if you're a teacher go to
ramseysolutions.com
forward slash teachers again that's
ramsay solutions
dot com forward slash teacher
no purchase necessary we just want to be
a blessing
and just celebrate the hard work these
teachers
are putting in for our young people
because i know chrissy to be honest
i was a knucklehead what no
no i don't believe that at all my
teachers she does she
ray clinton you need to go back right
now and apologize oh listen she deserved
five thousand dollars i ain't gonna lie
she probably deserved 50.
oh man thank you mitt mobile hey we'll
be right back
so
christie wright and myself anthony
o'neil ramsey personalities are taking
over this
hour right here on the ramsey show and
you guys guess what our famous ten
dollar sale
is back get the tools and resources you
need to make
real progress with your money and life
goals all for just
10 dollars america so that means
saving up to 60 on over 40
best-selling books like the total money
makeover
and ken coleman's the proxy the
proximity principle
these also make great gifts head over to
ramseysolutions.com
store to check out our 10 dollar sale
and there's more we've got a gift for
you too
you know we love you america so you can
also enter to win
our ramsey cash giveaway we're giving
away
500 cash every week starting this week
plus a grand prize
of five thousand dollars cash enter
daily for extra chances to win no
purchase necessary and check this out
you have to be 18 years
or older so text the word cash c-a-s-h
two three three seven eight nine
to enter now is debt-free degree ten
dollars too hey you know what
i i think it is business boutiques
business boutiques
there you go okay then listen here go to
college debt free start your side
business ten dollars
yes i love it man if y'all are not
text the word cash the three three seven
eight nine and head over to
ramsolution.com
store uh to get some good gifts get get
some good material to help you
change your future uh nathan is with us
in st louis nathan good afternoon how
can christy and i help
yeah uh thanks for uh thanks for taking
my questions so
uh i've got a question about uh
how to handle a situation with my two
sons i've got a 12 year old son and a
nine-year-old son
my 12 year old loves the idea of saving
you know we've talked about interest and
compound interest and he actually
started
uh a little business last fall and it's
somewhat exploded and he's he's
absolutely killing it right now
that's awesome it's funny roth ira and
uh
he is set on retiring when he's 50 and i
totally believe he will as a millionaire
and then i've got my nine-year-old who
uh you know when he has 27 dollars he
has 27
in the bank account he's looking up you
know games boys that cost thirty dollars
sure he's the second time
and so i'm i'm sitting here and i'm
talking with my wife
uh you know should we should we be doing
something for my nine-year-old i just
envisioned this scenario
20 years from now my you know my 12 year
old that time is going to be killing it
he'll be a millionaire
my nine-year-old is not going to have
anything he's going to say why didn't
you make me save or why
you know why didn't you help me save it
so i don't know if we should be
doing something for him even though he
he doesn't want to
he doesn't want to save or do anything i
i don't know i'm just kind of worried
about what that's going to look like and
in
you know in 20 years when one of my kids
is significantly better off than the
other
well here's the thing nathan the thing
that you're doing is something that i do
and lots of parents do
and you are making long-term assumptions
based on a child's very young age
and season now there are aspects of this
that you're probably right
it's personality driven they handle
money differently they're wired
differently
rachel cruz talks about this in her book
know yourself know your money we're all
wired differently
savers spenders and that type of thing
but to your point you can
shape and help facilitate good money
habits at a very young age the the
difference is while your older son
is very self-motivated to make money and
save money
your second child like a lot of second
children i will add i've got
one um isn't so self-motivated in that
particular arena so what you're going to
have to do is you're going to have to
create some external sources of
motivation
so for example if he never has to save
money to
pay for something that he wants then
he's never going to save money
whereas if you put some type of limits
and i don't know what this looks like
when they're nine years old you know
there's some examples in smart money
smart kids of
age-appropriate examples but like with
my kids you know
my children carter and conley are six
and four and a half
i will get them presents on holidays
christmas birthday that type of thing
outside of that i don't buy them toys
for any reason if they want a toy they
have to do chores
and they earn commission and they save
up their money and then they can buy
that toy
they do not get the toy unless they work
and save the money for it so i think for
you it might look like
figuring out what the what motivates
your second child
and then leveraging that in a very
healthy way not in a manipulative way
but in a healthy way to show
okay there's going to be some
consequences if you don't save
and there's going to be some reward if
you do save and when you start putting
that in place i think it will
force him to go against his nature a
little bit more
to learn these money habits because i'll
be honest i i have the
your second son's tendency i tend to i'm
the spender we were talking about this
anthony i'm the spender and
so i have to force myself with the
disciplines
to stay on track for what i want to do
so i don't want you to be discouraged
uh there is an aspect of their
personality that you're you're right on
point but it doesn't mean he's never
gonna have money he's gonna be broke
while your other son's a millionaire
i think it might just be you have to
facilitate that motivation a little bit
more than your older son who's more
self-motivated anthony you you
work with teens all the time and youth i
think what you said right there
christie's
is so good you know uh nathan i would
just definitely say on top of that
on what chrissy said and you may just
have to step in and be the father
and say this is what you're doing you
know you're
going to save you're going to have to do
this
now you can spend a little bit but hey
in this house
we save so we can build wealth and this
is what you have to do
there's a proverb that says train up a
child in a way that he or she should go
and so i i just want you to train your
sons
in the way that they should go
sure the um the other thing and you
probably already know this nathan but i
would just say pay
pay very specific attention to it
your sons are probably motivated by very
different things so
if you're anything like most parents you
know you have one child and you know
that child and you figure that child out
as best you can
and then you have a second child like oh
i totally got this i know exactly what
to do
i remember when colleen was born we're
like i know exactly how to swaddle him
give him a pacifier and put him to bed
and he hated swaddled and he hated
passport like oh you're a different
person
even from an infant and so just think
about what what excites him
what motivates him what does he get you
know excited about and how can you use
that to teach him
in the direction you want him to go but
not forcing him to be like your older
son or be motivated by the things that
your older son is motivated by because
he's a different person so
it's this lifelong journey of of
customizing your parent for the child
which can be exhausting but worth it and
pays off
as as your children are so different i
love it i love it doug is with us in
kansas city
good afternoon doug how can christy and
i help
hi guys um so i have reached a pretty
unfamiliar point in my life with my
money
and i am very addicted to spending money
and i found that i don't mind if i'm
paying bills saving it
whatever so we have one debt left
and it is our house okay we're we have a
plan to have it paid off in
seven months max but six months looks
very doable for us
okay so my wife and i were discussing
about what we were going to do
after that and we discussed it started
discussing
investing money and that opened up a lot
of options for us that we're not sure
what we want to do
we have two little girls so we would
like to
you know have an investment for their
weddings that we'll have to pay for
uh and college
college is kind of yeah
eight and eleven okay eight and eleven
so they're
they're still fairly young now the
college is kind of a trick for us
because we want to
offer them the option to have
us help them pay for college but in
return they have to
help pay for college hold their grades
and
you know if they if they have time for a
job have a job okay so we're not giving
them a free ride to college they still
have to earn it but we want to have the
option there to give them
a debt free scholarship yeah yeah i love
it so
let's do this and then the third thing
obviously is a retired extra retirement
expertise yo so
got you well hold on a lot we about to
go to break i don't want to rush this
answer
so when chrissy and i come back we will
allow you to complete your question
and then we'll have a conversation about
some options for you all right
so uh just sit tight and we'll be right
back this is the ramsey show
before we went to break we were um on
the line with doug in kansas city
and he um was asking some pretty good
questions and i didn't want to rush and
answer
um and and pretty much uh leave him with
not a good answer so doug how about you
uh remind us of your questions so we can
best serve you on this call
okay well we are planning on paying off
our last day which is our house in six
to seven months
and we were looking for somewhere to put
our money after that
we've started looking into investing and
we've decided that we would like to
start
investing for my two little girls that
are eight and 11 their weddings
and for their college and a
second retirement for me and my wife
okay awesome
all right um so let's talk about the
basics real quick man how much what's
your household annual income right now
uh it's about a hundred and sixty
thousand 160 k is what you all make
annually
you're 100 debt free i just want to
confirm this correctly right no consumer
debt so no car loans credit cards
student loans none of that all right
sounds good and then how much is your
mortgage right now
i mean how much do you have left on the
mortgage
49 000 oh wow yeah so you should be able
to pay that off
this year huh he said seven months yeah
yeah
seven months is what our safe number is
but i'm
thinking we can do it in six and that's
why we're going to hold off investing
until after the house i'm curious how
much is the house worth
about 250. cool how much do you have in
your retirement
i have a pension through my employer and
i have about three 10 in there right now
i don't have to see the new statement
okay anything else no okay cool so
you're looking at over half a million
dollars in retirement right now cool
um are you already investing 15
i am not i'm just what i get to my
pension to my employer is all i'm
investing in retirement right now
okay cool great so i do want to add to
that all right sounds good
um and you're not doing any investments
into like a 529 currently right now
right
no and we were wondering about the 529th
since it's specifically for school if
something were to happen and my kids did
not
maintain their part of the deal i am the
type of parent that is going to hold
through my word and not
support them in college
i totally understand that uh so what
what specifically is your question
a question for christina where to put
your money because you've got all these
options is that what you're saying
okay yes yes well i mean we we have the
baby
steps for a reason and you're obviously
on track with that with your paying off
your house and and you're investing
you're doing a little bit different but
you've got that pension and stuff going
on
here's the thing i i tend to look at
things not as black and white as either
or
i just like i like combination options
and so i think that you can say for all
of these things you're talking about
um because none of them are that urgent
right now it sounds like your daughter's
wedding your daughters are little
and some of these things you're talking
about uh you can start to put a percent
away for each of those and let that
money grow that's what my go-to would be
anthony what would you say
yeah absolutely so i'm gonna i'm gonna
go ahead and get on baby set four
uh doug i'm gonna go ahead and max out
15 so i'm going to
keep doing your pension um and i'm also
going to open up a roth ira
for um well you're at uh
your income is uh yeah so you're not
you're right there so i would do an ira
um so that way you and your wife can
have that
i still would open up a 529 doug and i'm
having a conversation
with my kids saying hey you are still
responsible to getting
into school okay your grades are going
to have to be important
um you are going to have to get some
grants and some scholarships but your
mom and i are being intentional
and making sure that hey we help you get
through school the key word there was
help
not pay help yes okay we're going to
help and then also man
i love your your your idea one of the
key things that
i'm really excited about for my future
and dave has done this you know dave
um has sewn into their his kids weddings
um and i plan on doing that so if you
want to part some funds into like a
mutual fund
uh for your kids wedding down the road i
think that's great one of the things
that i'm even starting to do
this year is park money in a mutual fund
for my kids
first house because i want to just start
doing that so i don't want to lock it up
into a retirement
so i'm going to put into a mutual fund
and whenever that happens
it's going to grow some compound
interest and i can have that
conversation with my kids and say here
you go
so i would definitely uh put your money
into the baby steps
max out your baby set number four at 15
go ahead and put a little bit into your
uh not a little bit but go ahead and
put some into the 529 whatever's
comfortable for you and your wife
um going ahead and finish paying off
this house because that's going to help
you get closer to your net worth of a
million dollars
and then also if you if you have some
leftover money
now definitely man i will go ahead and
start looking into a
a good mutual fund that's not covered
underneath retirement so you can start
saving
uh for the wedding if that's something
that you want to do down the road
okay that i i i i really like that
answer
i guess we lost you right there sounds
good but he liked it before we lost him
he liked the answer
you're two today that's two people
you've made happy today i mean chris
keep in count i feel like you're
doubting my capabilities on being a
ramsey personality right now
i just want you to know that i'm just
super super sure of your ability
to make people uncomfortable if needed
to get to the result they need
you're absolutely right hopefully i can
go for three because uh david is with us
in phoenix arizona what's going on david
how can
christy and i help all right hi
well nice to meet you guys um i do have
some questions i'm
25 years old i'm in school
and i'm pretty much trying to figure out
like what do i focus on right now as far
as
where my money is going so right now i'm
in school i'll be graduating in may and
then
um taking a gap year and trying to get
along to
medical school after that okay uh i
don't
really have debt so far other than what
i i have about 5500 debt that's
interest free that i plan to pay off as
soon as i graduate
what is it that we don't have um i
forget the exact term but it's basically
the subsidized
uh loan okay so student loan all right
yeah student loan enough time to guys uh
about 11 000
uh or i'm sorry 17 000 investments
uh probably about it now thousands
is cash and then i make about 60 to 100
000 a year
i do sales work so it's kind of variable
and particularly since i'm doing
part time around school where is this 17
000
is this in uh single stocks or is it in
mutual funds where is the
17 000. i have a rock matched out rock
ira i started uh this
past year 2020 yeah i
got about 6 000 in it and then i had
about 11 000
metals
real quick bro can you speak directly
into your phones to move the phone away
from you and bring it right back to you
because i
i'm hearing you kind of muffled a little
bit
can you hear me better now ten times
better wow there you are
yes there you are excellent
all right so where about that where's
his other eleven thousand dollars
invested
on precious metals oh no medals
okay so about 17 000 in investments
then and about 8 000 in cash and then
making about 60 to 100 000 a year
currently and so
kind of i'm i'm in school i'm working
and i
rent a house i don't own real estate
i'm just kind of wondering do i focus
right now on just
doing what i'm doing and just save money
do i
invest how are you planning medical
school
uh well i have two options really one
is to go to school here in
arizona likely u of a and get
obviously in-state tuition and work i'm
planning to take a gap year between
um finishing
my prereqs and so and so forth and then
getting into medical school
so i'll work during that period of time
and i don't really have a complete plan
yet on
what like i don't have the everything
funded i just plan to work and
try and save up as much as i can during
that that's what we need david
i can answer your question right there
before we get into any kind of fancy
things we could do with our money at 25
if you want to go to medical school
that's your a1 yeah you don't have a
plan and you need one you need to
price out the options of where you could
go where you can afford how much it's
going to cost and what frequency you
need to pay it
put it on paper in a budget in a plan
and make sure you get your debt paid off
and save up that money before you go now
if you're taking a gap year you can do
it
but you need that plan that's your
answer to your question is you need a
plan for what you want to do
ladies and gentlemen that was christy
wright and this is the end of that hour
this is the ramsey show
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money my name
is anthony o'neill host of the popular
youtube and podcast show
the table with your boy anthony o'neil
that's me
and co-hosting with me is the one and
only christy wright number one national
best-selling author
and host of the christy wright
show and also you guys i just have to
say this because i'm
excited about this hour because christy
has her uh academy opening
up next week business academy yep uh
opening up next week and it's only open
for four days i think am i right yeah we
only open twice a year so i
get a new class of people into my
coaching group and then i walk with them
and help them in their business for the
next six months so we won't open again
until fall
what yes it's going to be fun on monday
open on monday
where can they go business boutique.com
and we have a webinar
free webinar on monday uh which is kind
of a sample of my coaching
but i'm going to teach them how to sell
without feeling slimy so how to
actually turn fans into customers so you
can get sales into your business
and not feel bad about the process so
that'll be fun you go to
businessboutique.com
sign up and get your spot and your
worksheet for that free webinar on
monday and then yeah
the academy is open so budget talk to
your spouse
plan it get in while you can we close on
thursday
man and the price is amazing um you're
actually on my show on monday i know i'm
so excited i'm telling you all right now
so excited about that one
you want to go over to my youtube show
uh because christy is a fireball like
this
this woman when she talks about business
she gets
fired up about it she knows what she's
talking about and i think the thing that
i love about you christy is you
genuinely love helping people yes and
you want to help as
many people as you can and the price you
guys
is unheard of chrissy can do this much
higher
and scale down on numbers but she said
nope i want to help as
many ladies as i possibly can so
um and she uh her and i get into an
argument on my
show on monday that's so fun i love
arguing with you
all the people you're like at the top of
my favorite list
it's all in good fun i hope people know
that we pick at each other i hope people
know it's all in good fun
i love doing a show with chrissy she's
one of my favorites to do it man because
we have such a good time and so hey
this hour we want to talk with you if
you are a young lady or even a brother
and you want to
you have some business questions uh our
business expert is in
the building we only have two of them
dave ramsey and christy wright not
anthony o'neil
and so chrissy is here to take your
phone calls now if you want to talk
about money
uh i'm the number one guy dave ramsey is
number two
we can say what we want cause we have
the microphone that's right
so give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
kick off this hour
uh cindy is with us in kansas how can we
help you sandy
hey thanks for taking my call yeah um i
am trying to figure out a compelling
reason
to pay off our mortgage we've been
through all the
baby steps and so we have retirement
savings we have a cash reserve
i am working one more year before i
retire and my husband
is retired and so i'm max funding my
401k
until i retire and we just refinanced
our house
okay so our mortgage is 144 000
and the rate is two and a half percent
so we only really have a 600
a month mortgage so i'm trying to figure
out if we really should
start to pay down the mortgage and if so
what's the best way to do it
i hate to not max fund my 401k
and were about flush with cash flow but
i just
needed some input now what's your
household income
right now well i make sixty thousand a
year
working part-time my husband has some
earned income about fifteen thousand a
year but he also has
fifty four thousand a year in guaranteed
income with his pension and social
security
okay so that's a total what 120
000 or so yep which will only go down
by about 60 000 in a year in a year when
you retire
when i retire we'll still have his 54
000. okay cool
now any other debt outside of the
mortgage right now nope
okay cool love it and you have how much
cash do you all have in your savings
account
eighty six thousand dollars eighty six
thousand i know it's more than we
should and i don't really need that
there okay but
um it's there right now and it took
total investments in retirement what's
what's your law's income there
um we have about 450 in retirement
outside of that 86 000.
there's about 450 in retirement savings
some of that is guaranteed income as
well
okay cool so do you have um any kind of
retirement
checks coming in once on top of this
once you retire
no okay cool no not yet no so you're
looking for take it from our portfolio
but we're not planning on it until we
need to
yeah yeah i totally totally agree here's
my thing
and i don't have nothing deep to tell
you cindy okay
um and i'm not gonna try and convince
you with something deep i'm gonna be
real with you
having no payments mandatory payments
when you retire
that is all of the information that i
need for myself
and i know you're saying well it's six
hundred dollars anthony well that's
that's six hundred dollars twelve
hundred dollars every two months
uh eighteen hundred dollars every
quarter uh you know that's a lot of
money that if you and your husband can
just pay this
off and then you all would have how much
is the house worth
uh about 325 yeah 325
all right so listen if you keep the
money inside
of the 450 that's gonna grow 325 in the
house you are close to being a
millionaire
and you all can pretty much live off the
interest and the income that you all
have coming in
so if i'm in your shoes i am definitely
i'm going to max out my 401k because
you're absolutely right i'm actually
going to sit down and talk with a smart
vester pro
because with you just having a 600
mortgage payment you have
way too much just sitting there not
gaining compound interest
so i'm going to jump on the phone with a
smart vessel pro and i'm gonna figure
out how can i catch
up how where can i invest a little bit
more into maybe on a
roth ira right now uh so right now i'm
thinking you and your husband only need
maybe 15 grand in your savings account
you know
and then the other money i'm putting
that in there so we can save and invest
so should we take a chunk of that money
and put it towards the mortgage or
should we start
paying towards the mortgage extra each
month
from that savings from that cash real
quick
um one one better way to do it if you
pay the chunk then you're reducing the
amount of interest that you're paying
yeah versus spacing out over months
because you're while it's only 600
a month you have a percentage of that
that is interest only that you're just
paying for no reason when you don't have
to
and so if i'm you and you know you do
what you want to but if i'm you i take a
chunk of that savings like anthony's
talking about
and put that towards mortgage as a
one-time thing and make sure there's no
penalties in whatever your mortgage
agreement is
right usually there's not yeah then that
immediately drops
your principal down and then you don't
have the interest is significantly lower
on your remaining price here's what i'm
doing sending your case
okay if i'm your husband i'm saying um
wife
let's take fifteen thousand dollars part
that in our savings account
uh for emergencies uh and well if i'm
your husband
um yeah yeah if i'm your husband i'm
saying wife
uh let's put fifteen thousand dollars in
the savings that leaves us with seventy
one
thousand dollars that we can put towards
is 144
that leaves us with seventy three
thousand dollars and then let's focus on
attacking that over the next year before
you retire
now you retire with absolutely no major
bills
and you still have about 60 70 000
income coming in a year that's beautiful
that's beautiful
uh so that's what i'm doing and i am a
man and i am a husband
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
chrissy wright anthony o'neil ramsey
personalities taking over the rams show
during this hour
and ryan is in north dakota and he is
kicking off this segment ryan good
afternoon how can
christina help hi guys thanks for taking
my call
um i guess i have a few questions
i i downloaded the every dollar app
because i would like to get a budget
going because i'm looking at
getting some investments going if you
will say
i'm looking at getting like a disability
i guess it's not necessarily an
investment but
i guess it can since i'm a small
business owner
i'm looking to get some disability and
maybe some term life insurance
and stuff like that i have zero personal
debt
but i have about 120 000 in business
debt
and two of those loans are zero percent
interest
um so i'm not too terribly worried about
those ones
um the other ones i should be able to
pay off i would say by
august um based on the season we're
going to have here
so i'm trying to set up this every
dollar um
my budget but my my income is constantly
changing because i'm a seasonal worker
you know
we do landscaping snow removal and it's
stuff space you know always changing
from year to year
income is whether it fluctuates or
lowers so on that app
can i go and plug in what my
revenue is if you will say and
will that app give me kind of an idea of
what i can budget for
investing into disability and life
insurance
and what you know i should be obviously
contributing to my roth ira 6000 a year
you know i'm just trying to figure out
my next steps as
um where i should be going you know
growing growing my net worth if you will
say
yeah great question i'll tell you one of
the things that um
i'm with you i love every dollar and um
because i've helped so many women and
men start and grow businesses
uh one of the things i'd love to see in
the future is a every dollar for
business app we just don't have it right
now so
i know of a lot of business owners that
have used the every dollar app for
businesses
i just want to give you some tips on
things to keep in mind first
and foremost it wasn't designed for that
so it's not going to be perfect
it's not going to be a perfect user
experience for you you're going to have
to modify
you know some headers and the way that
you uh just the way that you interact
with it because it wasn't designed
specifically for business but overall
it's going to accomplish what you wanted
to do what i would recommend though is i
would
recommend you have separate budgets in
every dollar just like you have separate
budgets in real life and you should just
keeping all of your business and
personal finances separate so you can
just
simply use a second email address to set
up that every dollar account
business and then have an every dollar
account that you manage for your
personal
as far as the um inconsistent income
uh you know irregular income you're just
going to manage your budget one month at
a time
and the way that you will create a
business budget in every dollar
from a revenue standpoint is based on
projections and past years
actuals so you look at your last few
years if you know oh gosh every july we
have a huge july then when you make
july's budget
you're going to account for we're going
to pay off more debt that month and
you've got really low months there may
be some months that you are barely
making payroll or whatever that looks
like with your expenses and you may not
be paying hardly anything on your debt
and you just you create the budget month
one month at a time
based on the projections of what you
think your business will do and you just
modify
update as you go based on the actuals
in the year does that make sense
absolutely
which is currently what i'm doing now
i'm just not doing it on an app you know
i just do it on
on paper so i mean i guess i can just
transfer that
kind of broke down on paper as it is in
the app so that's kind of i think what's
what's confusing me is if you will say
yeah and i will say when you start to
input it it'll take a month or two to
get used to using it in this way but
once you do
it's it is such a better experience than
paper and because it has that
category specifically for paying off
debt it's just going to be this awesome
visual for you to remem
remember here's how we're paying down
here's the progress we're making
it's just i think it's going to help you
be even more motivated to pay it off and
then you can to your point
allocate the amount of money that you
want to set aside for disability for all
these other
expenses you're just going to plug them
in just like you do your personal
expenses like your cable bill your phone
bill whatever
it's just going to be a separate app a
separate account and those are separate
expenses so you already it sounds like
you know what to do i think it just is a
matter of setting it up
under a separate email address yeah
great great question thanks for calling
that's awesome
oh man chrissy i love watching you work
you kill it
elizabeth is with us in tennessee good
afternoon elizabeth how can
and christina help hey hey guys
hey oh my gosh you guys are the dream
team
we won we know that thank you
that's awesome how can i how can we help
elizabeth
yeah so christy i am i'm a dietitian
and i went into this field to help
people
lose weight get healthy um i hated
seeing the growing
obesity trend in america and seeing all
these
diseases that really could maybe not be
prevented but
at least helped if they were to lose
weight get healthy exercise
and that is why i went into this career
and i have ended up in long-term care
so it's totally the opposite of what i
really wanted to do
so how in the world i would love to i
would love to one day to
own my own practice you know how do i go
from
this job to private practice helping
people
lose weight and and get to a overall
better lifestyle
well there's so many different ways for
you to do it elizabeth and sometimes
that can be exciting because you have
lots of options
sometimes that can be overwhelming
because you have lots of options
you know even when you use the word
practice it sounds so official like that
could be way way way off
you could literally start helping people
right now
on the side through a blog or podcast or
consulting or courses there's so many
different
mediums for you to do what you do
and help people and there's so many
different ways to monetize it
what were you doing so i have been on
this side i have been i've been working
with a company that's like tell it it's
like teledoc
i've been working with them and it's
just been so slow
and i want to be able to move more from
the job that i am right now to more of
that more
picking up more clients through that
you're you're working for a company
though
you're not doing your own thing yeah
right yeah i'm not recommending you do
your own thing
and um again it's not the only option
it's not the only option but i'm saying
if you want to use your skills
experience and your why
your passion for helping people get
healthy
you don't have to work for a company to
do that you can take your skills your
certifications
and you can help people through all
these different mediums which is what
i'm saying
what i would recommend you do is i would
recommend you figure out what is what
what do you what's the way that you love
doing it the most
is it face to face is it something where
you would like to maybe create a course
or create something that you just put
out there and it continues to sell in
the background
do you like helping groups is it you
know what are the different formats that
you enjoy
and then look at the options to help
people through that format
i will if you'll stay on the line we
will send you
a copy of my book business boutique and
this is a plan
very unintimidating elizabeth okay so
don't think oh i'm not business minded i
just want you to read it even if you
don't start your own business
i just want you to read it and look at
it it will help you want to be business
minded
yeah it will help you explore your
options of how
that you can do what you want to do and
help the people that you want to help
and picking the right path for you and
just because this is so fun i'm so
excited you're here elizabeth
whenever you complete that whenever you
read the book call me back and we will
give you a membership to the academy but
you need to know what your business idea
is because it's really for people
already running their businesses
but call us back and i would love to
have you in my coaching group because i
want to help you
explore your options but then bring
those options and those ideas to life so
if you'll stay on the phone we'll we
will send you
a copy of business boutique anthony one
of the things i see a lot is
people they don't consider how many
different ways they could do what they
do
like this month we're celebrating
teachers yup you and i are teachers
not in the traditional school sense but
that's what we teach
it's a different way to do it good we
teach through courses we teach through
shows we teach through podcasts and so
on
so there's so many different ways for
you guys to do what you want to do
and if you're not happy in the way that
you're doing it or the company you're
working for
look at other ways to do what you love
to do absolutely
absolutely i love how you just sold into
her uh
i hope you understand elizabeth she said
once you do what you do call her back
okay
so she can get you inside the academy so
uh call her
and look her up on instagram at christy
b wright
christy you said yes yes christie tell
her
reminder hey you said that's right okay
call her
and if she don't do it hit me up i'll
remind her i would never
you watch it this is the ramsay show
christy wright anthony o'neal ramsey
personalities
taking over the ramsay show today and uh
this has been
the uh ramsay show with the christy
wright and the table
show all in one and it's so it's so so
fun
uh find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer for
custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply so chrissy
today's question comes from janaya in
north carolina my home state
i'm married with one child we earn 85
000 annually and have two car loans
goodness gracious
i'm pursuing a nursing degree but can't
get approved for a private student loan
good there's a thousand dollar balance
on my account
every eight weeks and i currently use
credit cards to pay it
can you help me find a better way to
continue my studies
i feel like you're going to take this
one so just go ahead and just get on
your soapbox i am here for it
oh my goodness 85 000
a year and you have two car loans
and you can't get approved for a private
student loan good
and you if there's a thousand dollar
balance on your account every eight
weeks how do i currently use and i
currently use credit cards to pay for it
this is crazy
can you help me find a better way to
continue my studies stop
bottom line you're racking up so much
debt
um one of the very first things chrissy
i teach people in this situation
is to just stop um is to step back
and take debt completely off the table
yes
it's not even an option it's not an
option uh debt when i'm talking about
student loans private loans credit cards
um buy here financing or school
financing no no take that completely off
the table
and what you do is it forces you to look
at
different options right and this means
if you're making eighty-five thousand
dollars annually let me tell you the
problem is
you got two car loans if you if you can
get rid of those
you can pay a thousand dollars every
eight weeks you know because i'm pretty
sure your car knows by themselves about
twelve hundred dollars every month so
i'm trying to calm down because you say
you tried to get a private loan
like you tried to get you try to get the
most expensive loan at that
this is ridiculous so here's what you
need to do
you need to pause you need to step back
and say you know what hey
i'm not going to do this anymore i'm not
going to put myself into debt anymore
take debt off of the table you need to
sit back and say you know what
hey how do we fix this situation okay
uh you need to get these cars paid off
you need to get them out
of your situation that's going to free
up some money right there for you to go
to school
you know and then also look at what are
some different opportunities out there
that can help pay for school uh i want
you to go into my scholarly.com go to
myscoli.com they have a lot of nursing
programs a lot of nursing scholarships
um out there my scholarly.com that will
help you out
but take that off of the table and start
attacking these car loans i would
honestly sell them
and go buy something cash so you can go
to school yeah just to acknowledge that
what you've been doing has not been
working for you
so so let's do something different
digging yourself in a hole is not going
to get you ahead
digging further in a hole with a private
loan is not going to help the situation
you've got to do something different
and i love how you say that ao take debt
off the table you get creative
and you come up with completely new ways
to do what you want to do
when it's not an option when it's an
option you'll take it it's the easy
route you sign your name you get a
credit card it feels like free money
it's not the easy route it's a different
longer
type of hard so we want you to have the
discipline up front to have the hard
route of doing some research on how you
get scholarships and pay this debt off
and it will pay off in the long run you
just gotta you've just got to do
something different this is not working
for you
and i feel y'all i feel your heat you've
seen her say anthony she needs to go to
school and so she can make more money no
no she's drowning in debt well anthony
you're telling her to stop going to
school
pay off her debt then go back and pay
cash for it it's going to take her
longer
who cares that's good the average person
chrissy it takes them about 20
years to pay back their student loans 20
years to pay back their student loans
there's 45
million student loan borrowers with 1.7
trillion dollars in student loan debt
and y'all want me to sit here and tell
this lady to be a part of that stat
no no this guy's shaking his head out
there like tell him anthony i'ma tell
him
i get frustrated when i hear this this
is the only thing i gotta do i'm gonna
make more money no i
interviewed uh and met with the dentist
christie a dentist
with nine hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt nine hundred thousand
dollars
what kind of dentist is he he's a broke
one
he's a miserable one and no
stop stop stop stop
step back get rid of these car loans
stop applying for things take a year two
years to pay off this stuff you all are
making good money right now
annually and if it takes you four years
to complete this program
i would rather you i would rather see
you work and work your behind off for
four years in a struggle for the next 20
yeah
bottom that's good bottom line that's
good oh man okay
we're gonna go out to david and talk to
him out in the beautiful state of
florida
good afternoon david how can we help hey
guys thank you for taking my call yes
um so uh i recently like
like two weeks ago found out that i'm
going to be a dad
congratulations thank you thank you and
and for some reason a video
from ramsay came up at some point and i
started looking into all this and
it got it caught my interest and
i just wanna i didn't know i was such a
normal person i thought i was doing good
but it turns out that
i'm very normal and i just want uh
advice on
what what should i do because i i think
the baby's due in december and i think
if i go
like gazelle intense like i've heard and
in the past two weeks
um i can pay off my debt except for
for the house and maybe get the three to
six months
um but i also want to do this in a
healthy way
for my wife she's gonna i mean she's
pregnant which is it's gonna be
an interesting time so i just want to
make it the right way
yeah i don't know if you have any advice
for that by when i'm sorry you said you
could pay off all your debt and get your
emergency fund by when
by some like i'm fine before
the baby is born yeah well first of all
congratulations
on becoming a dad and i'm so glad you're
here you're new to us you stumbled upon
the video
and two weeks in you're calling in to
get yourself prepared so well done
for calling i'm just i'm so glad you're
here um
and i think you have a great plan um the
one thing i would take into
consideration is how much
what kind of savings you have right now
do you have anything
probably like six six thousand okay um i
don't know
i don't have much and in terms of depth
i
have like 30k okay but
that's what i have what's your income
because it's if you can get it all paid
off by december you must be making some
good income
uh i'm doing between me and my wife uh
120 000. okay okay cool
okay um so here's the one thing i'll say
an ao you tell me if this is not the
right advice because this is this is
what i would do and again i'm not as
black and white on stuff sometimes i
like to just
find a happy medium on things because
your wife is pregnant and there always
could be unexpected medical bills
and you don't want that to be added
stress when you're already
you know worried about your wife your
baby etc um i still want you to attack
that debt i think you can i think you
can get gazelle intense you can
sacrifice you can get it paid off by the
time the baby's here
i just would not recommend you drop your
savings down to a thousand dollars
right now in the process like we
normally tell people
that extra cushion could be um necessary
in your specific situation and season
that you've got a baby on the way
and baby you know the whole um pregnancy
process is can be expensive with doctors
and that type of thing and you just want
a little bit more peace of mind
if anything were to happen that you've
got that extraction that's what i would
say ao i know we always say a thousand
dollars but what you you talking
about you're the real you're the real
money guy no not great advice chris
you're a spot on uh real quick dave
before we go to break matt how's your
health insurance is it pretty good
oh yeah okay i i did the research uh
what it covers and what it
did and it's pretty good yeah so man do
this put four more thousand dollars with
that six thousand dollars i'll give you
ten thousand dollars it's good cushion
to
uh just cover some medical bills along
this journey and then yes go ahead and
spend the rest
and attack this debt if you can get that
30 000 paid off
uh within the next you know six seven
months great but i agree with christy
make sure you have at least 10 grand in
that savings account to just give you
some cushion
just in case some medical bills come up
but man again congrats my
congratulations that is awesome
this is the ramsay show
today's scripture comes from psalms
chapter 50 verse 15.
call upon me in the day of trouble i
will deliver you
and you shall glorify me less brown once
said chrissy which i love this quote
when life knocks you down try to land on
your back
because if you can look up you can show
enough get up
i love that if you can look up you can
get up i like it i love that
john is with us in fort worth texas good
afternoon john how can christy and i
help
hey guys thanks for having me on yeah
sure so
my wife is about to receive a pretty
large sum of money
and i would uh we would like some advice
on how she can best utilize that to set
up her future
and potentially our future as a as a
couple cool great
um how much is she about to receive
about three point six million dollars
okay okay john you're not messing around
okay that's incredible i mean my my my
my
uh where's she inheriting the money from
him remind me asking
um she is a part owner while her mother
was a part owner of a business that her
family operates
and when she passed uh years back her um
sister and her split the uh the
ownership that her mother had in that
business
and they just sold that business wow
that's amazing so we're looking at 3.6
million dollars all right um
tell me about you all's financial
situation how much debt do you have
uh we just have a mortgage that has
about 132 000 left
132 k left on it okay and what shall i
combine income a year
uh our combined income before the
dealership sold
is about three hundred thousand three
hundred thousand all right
sounds good and then um
what are where let me ask you this
question um
i'm gonna i don't even know that
question i was gonna ask you
what what were some of the things that
you all need but i think right now how
old are you two
uh i'm 27 and she's 24. okay cool
so here's what i'm going to recommend um
clearly going to pay off the house when
you get the 3.6 million dollars you're
going to pay off the house
and even so if you all want to upgrade
the house i mean i'll have a problem
with that
but the key thing here is you need to
get uh connect with one of our smart
investor pros
okay and you need to get connected with
someone that's going to have a teachable
spirit
because right now you all have the
opportunity
to really make some major major
moves and there's only two things unlike
dave that i only invest in that's mutual
funds and that's real estate
and so i'm getting with a smart investor
pro to say okay hey how do we invest
this money
what do we do how do we make her mother
proud of this because she left it for
us and then also there's nothing wrong
with spending a little bit of it
and so i would just definitely get with
one of our smart vessel pros
to see okay how can we invest this and
then you and your wife sit down and talk
about okay what do we want do we want to
go get a bigger home
for our future family um is there
something we want to do as a nice
vacation
do we want to invest into maybe a small
business i don't know do we want to
invest into some real estate
um just really have a good conversation
but definitely giving one of our smart
investor pros that would teach you and
educate you
on how to win with this money and to set
you and your kids up to win
uh john when is she going to get it um
you should be within the next couple of
weeks here
okay so um a pretty i guess immediate
thing i would do
is i would get with your tax
professional we also have endorsed tax
professionals
um to help you know if there's certain
ways that you can manage the money to
reduce the tax burden that you're going
to have on you from that
so that's in addition to in combination
with the
investment conversation but i would just
that's such a large amount of money
that it will make a massive difference
how you treat it
and the tax implication from that so i
would do that as well but i i mean
congratulations that's amazing and you
there's so many options uh for what you
can do and if you do it right if you
invest
correctly even in addition to you know
upgrading your house or anything you
want to do with it like that
um it will turn into a lot more than
that yeah uh really fast
so that's that's incredible you guys are
an awesome spot yeah yeah
absolutely man thank you guys hey no
problem at all just you know when you
get it
sit it and just let it sit there for a
little bit uh
go out there and get some wise counsel
don't be in a rush to spin it get the
wise counsel
have the the heart and the ears of a
student
and and i'm pretty sure you all will be
well uh
daniel is in a beautiful city of raleigh
good afternoon how can we help
hey how are you doing um i really
appreciate
your guys faith and your guys focus on
finances and
how you're helping so many people um so
i want to thank you for that first
yeah thanks how can we help man yes yes
so um
i'm uh kind of not young and kind of
growing in this
financial knowledge um i wanted to kind
of know how to start off my finances
because i'm
a graduate student at uncw and i'm 26
and i have some debt from school
but i kind of wanted to know how to
start off my finances
in terms of the retirement fund and in
terms of
like what i need to start before i get
to the workforce yeah yeah
i think the number one thing that you
need to do um
and i want to say this man daniel how
old are you
i'm 26. yeah 26. this th this
is the the most important question you
can ask when it comes to your money what
do i need to do right
when you can be humble enough to ask the
question man
that that's phenomenal you're going to
be a bright bright bright young man in
the future
uh the number one thing man you can do
right now with your finances
is invest into yourself so how much debt
are you uh coming out with outside of
college
um so i would say around 45 000
okay i think that's around what i have
okay do you have anything in the savings
right now
i have two thousand savings okay two
thousand dollars in savings okay cool
and then when you graduate
what do you think your ballpark income
will be
um so i'm gonna try to go into the
biotech
field okay i think that it's gonna be
around
65 to 80. yeah i'm thinking more so
right around that 75 to 85
range as well all right so let's just
say 75 to be on the
lower side of my end all right and so
here's the thing man
would you graduate in college the best
thing you could do right now
is to attack this debt the best thing
you can do right now is for the next
three years i'm even thinking maybe two
and a half years if you
really really work hard is to live like
you're still in college
is to take this 75 000 and pay off to 45
thousand dollars
this way you're debt free by the time
you turn 28 and a half
then you're gonna put three to six
months of your expenses inside of a
savings account so this way by 30 years
old you're debt free with some money in
account
and by then i think you're going to be
making about 85 90 stretching to a
hundred
so now at 30 years old you're making six
figures you are debt
free you have a fully funded emergency
fund and daniel let me tell you this man
a study just came out
that nearly 57 of the people in america
christie
can't even afford to pay us an emergency
that's up to 600
57 so the fact that you get out of debt
the fact that you have at least three
months in your savings account you are
ahead
of half of your friends and that's what
i want to see you do
at your young age now you're going to be
tempted when you get this checked
uh you're going to be tempted to look
good and you know um you sound like
you're a single brother and so
any kind of single brother that has a
good head on his shoulder making a
little bit of money the ladies are
coming you know the ladies are coming
and so you know keep your head on right
uh so that way when you do find your
wife
at least you're out of debt don't look
at me chris you know i'm telling the
truth
you know but i i want to see you win man
and so that's what i would recommend
crystal you have any
uh no i love what you said about the
paycheck because you get this income
it's like oh it sounds like so much
money it feels like so much money i've
never had this much money
you don't you're right you don't have
that much money because you got this
debt you get rid of this debt and then
you can enjoy that income in a different
way but
right out of the gate pretend like you
don't have that live on
hardly anything and you'll get it
knocked out so much faster and then
you do get to enjoy that income and it's
a good income you you will have earned
it you just got to get this out of the
way first yeah you want a wife down the
road daniel
of course only god's hearing a woman i
like that yes sir
um so let me tell you man and i can say
this on the ramsay show
i think that the coolest thing and and
the most
um uh the best thing i think you could
do for your future wife
is to think about her now is to be a
good steward of your single season and
say you know what i'm going to get
myself prepared
for the future and doing that by paying
off your debt
doing that by being intentional with
every decision
and every choice you made today is
setting you up to win
and i know your future wife would be
like thank you so much
for thinking about me when you didn't
know me huh yeah i
like that i feel like i'm about to go to
church let me get off this show y'all
chrissy thank you so much for rocking
with me so fun uh james shout and kelly
uh for uh producing this amazing show in
america
thank you all for listening to christy
and myself anthony o'neil right here
on the ramsay show keep it live we'll
see you here real soon
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you